everybody welcome to live coding with
Jessie I'm Jessie and today we're gonna
finish the component that we started
yesterday I made a lot of changes so
first thing I'm gonna do is cover those
changes before we get started with the
coding this is my first time using the
new webcam with my my home office setup
so let me know if anything is weird
hopefully the picture quality is a
little bit better it should be but I I'm
getting like from from my point of view
the audio is way off from the video as I
see it in OBS I'm hoping it's not like
that for you all please let me know what
would it's like for you and my computer
is really sluggish while I'm running
this okay so the audio and video seem to
be out of sync I also prayed that all
right let's let me see what I could do I
tried to look into how to fix that
yesterday but I couldn't find I couldn't
really find anything that seemed to
apply with what was going on yesterday
with a stream so while I'm explaining
this I'm just gonna check over on my
other screen some some options
it looks like there's there's quite a
few options here to choose from on a
Google search John said time for a new
machine yeah I it would be really nice I
I do have one other thing that I can try
it was just gonna be a lot of extra
setup but I can I I can run OBS on a
different machine and then that would
let my computer my that I'm actually
coding on it wouldn't have to handle all
the load of running OBS so maybe that'll
be my next step
it looks like I can set an audio delay
yet maybe oh uh let me add an audio
delay
we the settings real quick and add that
in if this doesn't work I guess I'll
just go to the code
the strain or output audios probably
where I need to go
cinq awesome alright let me see if I can
add this delay
all right is this is this better at all
you know it actually let me try can you
hear me all right that seems to be so
the the webcam itself has a microphone
so I wonder if I switched to that if
it'll give it'll be better synced all
right looks like it's still off from my
point of view but I'm not sure
all right so I think so I switched mics
to different mic and I think that I just
set a delay of 300 milliseconds but I'm
not exactly sure all right so let me at
least show you and explain what what's
going on here and maybe I can try to
adjust the settings of bed based on on
your feedback I'm gonna adjust the
settings like drastically
you
alright so in the spot where I think I
can add a delay I just added an audio
delay of 10 seconds
alright so let's say the volume is drops
okay I'm a little bit farther away from
the webcam mic let me see if I can
adjust the volume
is the volume any better now
all right just keep keep let me know
whether it's getting better or worse and
I'll go back to it but for now I I do
want to show you what I've done so I'm
sure most of you remember Harshit he's
been not in the stream quite as much
since I've been streaming later on and
it's it's really hard to watch because
of the timezone difference but hard [ __ ]
gave me some good advice
to use so called react scroll I think
that's what it's called
yeah react scroll to help with handling
the scrolling instead of trying to do it
ourselves and you know I really wanted
to use what we had already used in the
previous project because I thought that
would save us a lot of time but as we
saw yesterday it ended up being pretty
difficult there were just so many pieces
in different places that I I didn't even
realize they were there because number
one it's been a while since I worked on
my project but also most of that work
was from a pull request and I didn't do
it myself so having seen the code and
not actually written it myself it just
was a lot harder to try to adapt it so I
think this is probably gonna be a better
way to do it so far it's it's working
well so I want to give you just a very
brief overview of what we've done in
terms of the code and let me make this
code a lot bigger that's pretty small
Wow this is quite slow I see what I'm
gonna do actually let me I'm gonna
change my display let's see there we go
let's change this display let's get rid
of this and
[Music]
let's see that looks like it's in sync
it's it's much better to sell it better
do you are so I might just go with this
one then and maybe oh you know just just
go with this for now and then try to
work out the difference I'm gonna switch
back to the normal microphone that I
usually use and so the audio will be you
know back to normal okay that'll be
something I just need to work on
maybe after I stream today if I have
time I'll work on getting the the other
computer set up to run OBS alright so
for now let me make some space get rid
of this side bar I don't need that
okay John says the video is fine but the
sound is out works fine enough sound is
now in sync okay awesome alright that's
cool I think probably my this this
laptop is just not powerful enough to
handle that and so my audio is just
gonna be out of sync so I don't think
I'm gonna make it work with with this
computer and that camera so I need to
figure some other solution out with
another computer alright and now let's
get to this I do want to show you all
maybe I'm one of the breaks so remind me
if you're interested but I'd like to
show you all one of the side projects
that Harshit and Nikki have been working
really hard on and give you an update on
that this we haven't we haven't looked
at it in the stream in quite a while
okay so here's what we have so far we've
brought in well if I can click the write
the rate component I'll show you what we
had so far okay so we imported let me
see we actually imported a lot so we
imported all of this stuff from react
scroll it's a link events animate scroll
a scroll and then scroll spy and
scroller just as an aside here we are
using a component called link on other
pages and we're getting that from from
next if we were to use that component on
this page we could import link as
something else and that would reduce the
confusion so we probably will do that
and I forgot to set my timer Oh cuz this
area
so we've added basically everything
everything where you see these these
blue lines and the green line here this
is all added sew-on component did mount
we're basically just setting event
handlers right in this case the the
scroll and then we have some functions
that we're not using right now so we'll
probably take out but I copied and
pasted heavily from the example if you
want to check out react scroll let me
let me throw a link in here for you
thought I had it here I guess I don't
let me grab the link for react scrolls
so that you all can can check out this
package there we go so the links in
there now if you click it and it doesn't
work
please try copying and pasting it okay
so we'll probably get rid of scroll to
top don't really see the need for a
scroll to top function on this
particular page but it's good to know
it's there because we should probably
use that on the search page and were you
definitely using this scroll to function
so you could you know scroll to a
certain element and you can see you can
set different things like duration delay
you can even set like the type of
animation so really nice I'm not
probably not gonna mess too much with
the type of animation because that's
kind of thing that could get me off
track for a while just testing things
out and then like the grand scheme of
things it's just not that important for
this one particular part of the site
let's see
yeah some of these will have to work out
and see like do we really need we're
only using one type of scroll so may not
need some of these and then of course
when the component unmount weight we
remove our event listeners now in terms
of markup we've added this I've added
this div I put in some inline Styles in
the div but they're not working for me
right now so that's the number the first
thing we're going to work on are these
styles to get it in the right location
but we just have an unordered list and
then within each list item we have that
link component not to be confused with
the one we've used elsewhere from next
this is the link component we're getting
from react scroll and we've just set our
class is active so when we're scrolled
in that particular spot so when we're
inside that component that element on
the page that has an ID of Spring then
this link is going to have the class of
active and we can attach and I have
attached CSS classes to that right now I
just have spring in summer
sorry but we'll end up with you know all
the seasons who have four four links and
the only other change that I needed to
make was in our container so it's the
second content container we changed what
I changed this ID I should say I added
the ID of spring and then I added in
another container below that and gave it
the ID of summer just so that we had to
to work with the tests all right so all
in all
once we get rid of everything we don't
need I think this will end up being less
code and it will be more centralized in
one place I mean yes we're bringing in a
whole nother NPM package but in terms of
like cluttering our components way less
clutter all right now let me show you
what it looks like so let me go to
missionary outreach
okay so right now I can't even see it so
something I did with the styles are
really messing things up so I'm gonna
inspect here because I know in the
markup it's it's right below this so
even though we can't see it on the page
it's it's obviously still gonna be in
the same place in the markup so that's
where we're going to search for it well
mess with the Styles a bit right here in
dev tools and see if we can figure out
you know what to do I think I pulled
over the styles from our other project
that Resource Center project it's it's
our seedot Franciscan University if
anybody wants to check that out and I
believe it's the planning guide page
would be slash planning - guide and I
think we had that menu positioned yeah
let me make this bigger we had that menu
position like in our in our Dom tree we
had it like up at one of the higher
levels so think that made a difference
so I'm just gonna get rid of a lot of
these Styles right now just to see does
that make any difference at all and we
could see it does not so the one thing
that I think is messing this up is this
position fix but if we want it to behave
in the appropriate way we need that
sorry for the awning I've I've been
having like I've been so drowsy tired
all day I I thought I was gonna fall
asleep so let me just click it just to
show you alright so when you click it it
does take you to the right section
so that works I did have to use an
offset of negative 50 pixels so we could
still see this because the ID is
actually on this container and not on on
the title because we want the scroll spy
to detect that it's inside of this
container the whole way down when we're
scrolling otherwise it would just very
briefly have the class of active and
then once this was off the screen it
would go away and that would be no good
all right you know it and Nikki says
give it a ridiculous Z index just to be
sure
all right let's let's try that let's put
put all these back on and then give it a
z-index big Z index actually you can see
where is it it looks like it's putting
it way down in the bottom let's see if
we go see if it puts it ah yes okay all
right so if it needed at least we can
see it on the screen so right here in
the corner let me make this bigger so
it'll be easier so here in the corner we
have this spring and summer
mm-hm but really what we need
this is kind of odd I don't know if you
can see this but the background color is
off here it's white here and then it's a
table weight I don't know what's going
on with that you know what I think the
student that's working on this page
brought over a bunch of styles from the
HTML CSS version of the page that he did
first and I think some of them are
conflicting so there's there's a few
areas where the styles are a little off
it's not really a big deal we'll get
that sorted out okay I guess what I'm
thinking is we may have talked about
this yesterday is that this menu won't
this menu will stay here on the page so
it you won't see it it won't go up here
as you scroll so here's how I think we
can make that happen you all please let
me know if you have a better idea I'm
definitely open to suggestions so by
default this will be positioned here on
the page so I think we can
how can you accomplish that we'll get
into the CSS of that in just a second
but then since we already have the
scroll spy set up we'll just check out
there's got to be a way to make
something happen like fire off a
function that we create when we get to a
certain place or change something we got
to be able to change something when we
get to that certain spot and at that
point the Styles will change so that
this goes to
like very similar to what it is right
now so let's
let's go back to the code I think we can
do this
[Music]
if we have
ooh Nikki saying use position sticky yet
is that's what's the support for
position sticky let's check that out
all right well I mean obviously Internet
Explorer 11 is not supporting it I'm not
really that worried about Internet
Explorer 11 I've told you all how I feel
about it if anybody wants really wants
to they'll ask me and I'll answer to
tiendas the supreme yeah so I'm not
gonna worry about Internet Explorer 11
for right now let's try position sticky
and I don't know that I've ever used
this before I remember someone bringing
it up on the stream before and we
checked it out but I don't know if I
ever used it if I did I forgot so let's
play around with it I don't know where
what let's just look up what yeah pretty
sure I'll get a link right to mdn from
here there we go
well polyfills maybe we can't make this
work all right here's a sticky position
if you haven't used MDM before I highly
recommend it so it's the Mozilla
developer Network anytime you search for
anything in HTML CSS JavaScript and I
don't know what else the mdn article on
that will probably probably be one of
the top search results so it's it's very
thorough if you're a beginner it could
be a little intimidating because there's
so much information it for beginners I
recommend if if you're confused by all
this scroll down to the examples and
check out the examples first for me
starting out and even now the examples
sometimes make it clear to me
immediately whether or not this is gonna
work and then if I think it'll work and
I'm interested I'll go back and read and
learn what I would I need to about it
but otherwise it can take some time to
get through everything and try to figure
it all out so let me just go through
this quickly I'm not gonna read it out
I'm just gonna glance at it
all right
let's go down to the sticky area
the sun's perfect for us a Stickley
position element is treated as
relatively positioned until a cost
crosses a specified threshold at which
point it is treated as fixed it's
exactly what we were gonna try to
implement ourselves with JavaScript okay
which one
ones so which one has the idea of one
I'll see it in there oh okay I like that
that's nice
okay
I just see that Franky just joined us
welcome thanks for joining us don't
worry about being late alright so let's
try it out it seems like all I really
need is this position sticky and then
I'll get value from the top let's go
back here and let me get rid of that was
weird
that max-width is messing things up
oh-ho can you believe it works just like
that ah that's amazing
check that out wow that's cool all right
a few things I don't want to try okay so
I when it really is position fixed it's
nice that it doesn't take up this space
here so I want to do something about
that I definitely don't want it taking
up so much space
I don't y'all can hear that but my phone
just keeps going off constantly okay I
do have some work messages let me just
check and make sure it's not emergency
okay there is a change I need to make to
the bulletin website but I don't think
it needs to be made until the end of the
week all right so no no emergencies okay
thanks for being patient I check that
out all right so let's see interesting
oh it's this position rice not working
let's see if we can do there we go nice
alright so I know floats are old-school
but in this case a float does exactly
what we wanted to so we're gonna go with
a float and then we're gonna put a
margin right margin if I think it that's
right
there we go right of 16 pixels okay I
always like to have at least 16 pixels
here because if you can see we have this
scroll bar that shows up and on browsers
where this happens we definitely want
enough space that you could still read
and click on these I believe Internet
Explorer scroll bar is like always there
and it's big so I know we're not really
trying to support it but something small
like that I think is it's definitely
worth doing because you never know how
browsers look to on different operating
systems so I think this scroll bar is
like the slimmest one and on Windows I
believe they're a little bit thicker all
right
wow that was super easy I guess
what's going on here is it's not exactly
working something happened and it's not
working
so that active class is not working
right but let me check the time all
right only about two minutes let's let's
get these styles over into a CSS file
quickly so I'm just going to copy these
and we'll do position sticky so this
we'll be I'm just using this missions
thought CSS that we already had and
[Music]
actually I had that on the div and that
div doesn't have a class right now we
need to give that davis let's get rid of
these styles give it a class name of
scroll spy container position sticky and
then we'll paste this in I don't have
Auto formatting set up for my CSS
unfortunately I'll have to manually do
that there we go all right cool let's I
don't think we changed anything else
let's give it a refresh just to be sure
the styles don't auto refresh so when I
change the with the CSS files
it's taking quite a while why is that
happening I think I messed something up
here
I know none of those areas would explain
it okay let me take a five-minute break
I'm gonna go to the live chat and answer
some questions and when we come back
we're gonna troubleshoot the stuff that
I've apparently broken okay I didn't
notice right off at the very beginning
of the stream towba sallow first time
here if you're still here - welcome to
the stream thank you so much for for
joining us today sorry about all the
technical difficulties at the beginning
Oh Phoenix said earlier there's a weird
noise let me know if there still is a
weird noise there shouldn't I don't hear
anything now nobody is home at my house
so if you hear something weird
let me know again yeah I can't hear
anything
James Ross asks if there's any update
with my kids brain project so the last
thing that happened with that project
was I had a video call with Alex
Castillo and he works with brain
computer computer interfaces and
JavaScript and he does presentations on
it at different conferences he used to
work at Netflix and he has his own
company now but there is focusing on the
brain computer interfaces so he he was
working on making the link so we did
some testing to try to get the brain
computer interface connected via
bluetooth directly to a website right
through the through the browser and we
were successful at getting that to work
I did send him some some test data so he
was gonna try to work with that to get a
link so that the data can be readable so
I have no idea how long that's going to
take in the meantime I can probably
start working on like the front end of
it and just basically like mocking data
so I'm hoping to get started on that
soon it's I mean it's if there's just
always things going on you know there's
always things to do so hopefully I'll
get to that it is kind of high on my
list so oh I will update you all as as
we go on
John Soto says question why not you
scroll into view we could you said since
we are already using this package to to
track the the scroll I'm just using the
tools that are available there to move
the to do the scrolling so I think this
is a case where there's a lot of
different ways to do this and I don't
know if this way is the best way but so
far it is it seems to be working
John it SoDo if there's any particular
reason why you think's wrong of you
would actually be the better way to go
please let me know because I'm
definitely interested in doing this you
know the best way I can John Hanson says
bringing over a premade react package
can be great though I find that you have
to put trust in the dev of that package
yeah for sure for sure I think that's I
mean that's an issue I think everybody
deals with now there are very few like
large-scale projects where everything's
built from scratch I mean like anybody
using react for projects is trusting the
devs behind react it's just I don't know
that's just the way web development is
now for better or for worse we're all
able to build really cool things and and
build on you know what everyone else was
working on and it's really awesome it's
great collaboration but at the same time
yeah it does require that trust so I
guess it is a good idea to at least look
at the package a bit look at the github
repo see some of the issues what if
people said about it how many people are
actually using it you know see basically
if there's anything that just looks
weird
in terms of you know there's nobody use
this maybe there's a reason why nobody
uses it
are there ton of issues that that never
get closed that's probably a warning
sign too so at the end of the day though
you're right you just you have to trust
that the people that made the package or
did a good job and you know definitely
make sure to test things out on your own
and not just trust that it's it's always
going to work
okay let me
let me start this and let's go okay I
broke everything so let's check that out
first and see why why it's broken now
probably because I've messed up the
width
[Music]
she seems
all right me
I think that maybe the float:right is
what's the one
so
while I'm waiting for that to reload I'm
just gonna go through okay all right
that did work now
some of the functionality we needed I
think because I think we have all the
functionality now it it scrolls with a
page but only when we want it to you
click a link and a ghost the right
section oh we're still missing that
change in when we have that active class
so that was something that was working
before I started the stream so something
that I've done since then as has changed
it so that plus this positioning is what
we need to we need to fix all right let
me I'm gonna save this I'm gonna try one
more time just to see like what what's
going on is this is to say oh he's gonna
happen and it looks like is okay oh nice
all right cool it it worked this time
all right excellent at some point we may
not get to it on this dream but we'll
definitely want to make sure that that
side navigation goes away we don't
really have room for it on a smaller
screen all right all right cool all
right so now that's that sorted and we
need I need to figure out why the active
class is not being applied here so let
me inspect this so we can see if it's
being applied so it should be on I think
it'll be applied here on the a tag okay
yeah so it is being applied it's just
the CSS that needs to change
okay and that makes sense because the
styles are actually on the LI right now
okay
oops alright let's check it out
it'd be nice if I could get the class to
apply here but I don't think it's gonna
work like that Nikki just said it looks
like masonry is just being a bit slow on
this machine yeah I think you're right
it's just this this machine just can't
handle streaming very well
that John said looks like this coding
session has been conquered almost we're
close we're really close okay so if I
all right let me ask this is there a way
in CSS to where I could change the style
of a parent if the child has a certain
class added I don't I don't know if
that's even possible let's go to Google
man no you can do it on what is it like
hover and stuff like that
alright John saying that styled
components would work really well here
because you could just switch the
attribute name with JavaScript
heeey
actually let me let me look at this from
a different perspective here so I want
to try two things one is Nikki's idea
and it's what if we move the link
component outside the allies will try
that first that seems to be the most
straightforward thing if it works then
great we're done if that doesn't work
then what I want to do is let's move the
styles on to the a tags and see if we
can get a similar effect by putting the
styles on the a tag whoa Nikki there's a
parent selector no way how did I not
know about that
oh wait a second is there really a
parent selector or is that just a
suggestion from CSS tricks
all right I'm looking it up right now on
can I use on the other screen
I don't think that's it I think I found
the drying suggest there's a 4000 let's
try it then
seems like it's not but a lot of people
want it yeah I want it
alright let's let's try moving this
around
this is gonna be really weird I don't
think I don't know if this will work I'm
just gonna try it with one just to save
time
did it refresh it
I don't think it did let me refresh
okay John says the parent selector will
be out in CSS for alright so I guess I
can't use it yet
[Music]
oh you know what I didn't the CSS is
still not not right so it did work in
you know that we now have an li inside
of this a tag which actually that it's
weird but it works so we need EV Li si
need to have a active Li there we go
okay that looks like it will work so
really wish I didn't have to reload this
again but I do she's so slow hope I'll
check my time while we're waiting all
right about 10 minutes I think 10
minutes is more than enough to fix this
problem hopefully
I'm checking out the live chat while I'm
waiting for that to load nikki says
disclaimer I've never actually used
position sticky just a possible answer
for the problem you should do what you
want good to know thanks to that there's
also the CSS tricks article on something
is also a great resource I go to that
when mdn starts to confuse me which is
often ok that's that is good CSS tricks
--is is pretty good alright cool check
that out so we have when we're not on
that area we don't have that little
border and now when we scroll to it hey
there's that little border perfect
perfect
o-haru hides nice really cool all right
I like that I'm thinking maybe the
colors could be different we're not
really using that yellow color and this
site so we may want to change that you
know may may or may not want to use the
gold color for this you know maybe we'll
go with you might want to go with
regular color text with gold on the side
green text was gold on the side I mean
there's a lot of combinations so I'm
probably not gonna get into that for
this dream I mean it's pretty basic just
changing hex colors on on text here yeah
all right very cool so what I do need to
do though is go back in and make sure I
change the mark-up for that second link
as well so that was I believe Nikki's
idea to put the LI inside of the link
tag and that was a great idea honestly I
thought it would not work but it was
such a straightforward change that it
was definitely worth the try and it
turned out that it did work
for some reason my auto floor mat is not
correcting this mess that I just made
probably when I go to commit it will get
corrected so I'm not gonna worry about
it but I do want to wait for the Refresh
just to make sure it's working and I
don't think it'll work go down here
because the page isn't long enough I
can't actually scroll into the section
so I won't be able to test that out but
we see if we can see yeah I get it won't
work right now so if I add some like
demo content to this section we could
see if it'll work but I'm pretty
confident that it will I tested it out
earlier with some different stuff and I
was getting a change in the in the
classes for each section and we can see
like the the Li is here so these look
the same all right let's save that and
let's do get status what why is my
chrome bouncing does it want to tell me
I don't know
let's do commit now yeah this looks good
okay cool I think there's some low -
stuff we can get rid of like the for
each I believe in the map values you
know I wanted I we can for sure get rid
of the for each but I do want to
double-check about map value so maybe
I'll maybe I'll wait and double-check
that later on before I just get rid of
it but for now we can do a get add and
[Music]
and we'll run through
[Music]
so we're gonna add a feature and this we
add completed I added the word completed
in there because I think I may have made
a commit already that said we added this
when we had just added some of it and it
didn't work yet so while that goes
through all the tests and everything I'm
gonna go over to the live chat and start
answering some questions so let me
scroll up to where I left off
how Devin says you should listen to
everything everything spring summer
winter dread while you work on this
I left all right I have to look that up
I don't think I've heard that Nicki said
is it bigger than 16 pixels on Windows I
think that's a song by the scrollbar
[Music]
Devin says ie scrollbar thought we were
dropping support yeah what Windows ie
for sure it's a big scrollbar but I
think on Windows in general every
browser has a big scrollbar
it's been a while since I've used
Windows so I I'm not a hundred percent
sure but I think the last time I tested
on Windows which is probably the last
time we launched something new I I think
there were large scroll bars even on
Crum Devon says well this even be usable
on IE can you just target IE and show a
sub nav for spring/summer at the top
yeah we'll see I'm I'm not even going to
try to make it a hundred percent useful
and ie
I mean like think about this is like one
page on an entire site that's gonna have
thousands of pages most likely I'm okay
if one menu looks a little bit weird
I'd actually it would be cool to see
what it falls back to I mean I am
interested in trying it on and it
Explorer just to see what happens
there's got to be some like fallback
position does it fall back to fixed in
that case it'll still work it'll just
look weird when it's you know in the
hero section
Devon says mixing to top and
margin-right seems weird to me yeah it's
it definitely is weird it there's some
weirdness going on with the styles and
markup for this component so I think had
I made it from scratch instead of
importing a little bit from previous
projects I maybe wouldn't have done it
like that but this works so I'm
definitely I say I'm pretty sure that
there's probably a better way to do it
it probably wouldn't look different to
the user and it probably wouldn't result
I guess I tried to save that web page
all right that's why chrome was bouncing
yeah so I don't know that it would be
worthwhile for me to really worry about
about that at this point so I mean just
to be clear I think writing good code
and writing the best solutions is
important but you don't always have time
for that like I don't think I could make
sure all this code is as close to
perfect as possible and still get it
launched on time so what we have to
settle for then is does it work and is
the code at least reasonable you know
that's that's my experience you know
what actually working on projects with
deadlines and things is that you just
you just have to do it sometimes so but
anyway I entirely agree that setting the
March and works but the reason we had to
do that obviously was because of the
float right so we need that offset for
the scroll spy so you can see that come
into play like so we need that top value
for the I'm sorry for the sticky so like
you see that come into play of this 50
pixels
but then we also need the margin since
we decided to use the float which is
pretty weird to use with top as well
that's why we needed that margin so
definitely weird but it gets the job
done
and I think yeah it went through
everything so I also fixed the test so I
remember yesterday I was saying that the
tests were like taking forever
so I believe it was Nikki that found the
commit where I broke everything and so I
was able to go back and and change
everything at some point I made a commit
that reverted to an older version of the
package.json file I'm not exactly sure
how that happened but it was about five
days ago and so all this week this past
week two tests had been acting weird
that was why so now it's all worked out
we have our test back and they run
quickly so I'm gonna run to get pushed
to make sure that is on github so y'all
can check that out if you'd like a link
to the github repo is in the description
Frankie asks if I'm feeling better today
oh thanks for asking Frankie this
morning I felt good but then after a
couple hours my energy was just gone and
I I was actually felt so good this
morning I was thinking about working out
I ended up not and just started work
like right away I did have to take the
kids to school so I got the kids ready
and I took them to school and I don't
know I still might work out I'm thinking
about it
I just don't want to go I don't feel
100% but I don't want to go too long
without a workout because I know like
with my depression if I go too long
without working out I'll get depressed
so even though my legs are still sore
from my last workout that was two days
ago it would be better for my mental
I think if I just do it so hopefully
I'll do it and but I think this this
antibiotic that I'm on is starting to
help the congestion is almost completely
gone so I'm glad it my bladder seems
like it's working because I honestly
I've had this on and off I don't know
what it is some type of virus or
something I don't know on and off for it
seems like months who knows how long it
really was but it just seems like it's
been so long well I appreciate you
asking and thank you Oh John says try
out right 18 pixels all right I'll try
that I'm not gonna try right now I want
to test first I think it looks okay with
16 but I'm not opposed to bumping out a
bit more if we need to especially for
people using windows
Nietzsche says I also thought it
wouldn't work so flipping the lis and
the link tags so that the allies inside
the link so he's saying thought that
wouldn't work what are the implications
of not having the ul Li structure but a
ul a structure a to the truth I don't
know but we may want to think about that
I think visually there's not gonna be
any implications but for screen readers
there might be alright maybe I'll have
to look at that wondering I mean based
on the position in the markup that's
actually a really good position I think
for screen readers because it's like a
submenu that comes in there
we'll have to see I mean maybe I might
just have to try out just a basic screen
reader that comes like on a Mac and see
what it says when it gets to that point
I mean they'll still show up as link
tags so user would know that it's it's a
link
I wonder how misleading anchor tags are
for screen readers right because if they
show up as a link would a screen reader
you just describe it as a link like to
another page when it's really not it's
just the length to a different spot in
the same page and like what happens when
that jump happens there's a screen
reader also jump down I'm getting kind
of off the topic here but that's that's
really interesting I just don't know you
know what is doing that is jumping to a
different section in the same page even
a good idea for accessibility I don't
know I need to learn more about that
there's like a whole world of you know
making your website more accessible that
you know I just don't know enough about
John's pretty sure that Li is not needed
on ul also says chrome used to have an
experimental flag to make a skinny
scrollbar that shows wider when hovered
not smart to develop with that flag on
yeah I mean I could see it would be
easier to actually click a wider scroll
bar to scroll up and down but I don't
know I think that would be annoying
trying to develop stuff with that I mean
you're basically changing the width the
window width on hover that's not I mean
it's only a couple pixels too depending
on where your breakpoints are that could
totally like make your whole layout
reflow just on hover okay Nicki said I
do have something on my package.json so
imma just key that I need to remove but
also says it's not a huge deal since
it's not use now
okay so I'll it's not hurting anything
than to be there so I'll remove it at
some point I guess yeah thanks for
letting me know about that that saved me
so much time you know earlier when you
when you showed the commit where all
that changed
Arthur says hey Jessie I'm learning
front-end development my problem is that
I switched between HTML CSS and
JavaScript as priorities I try to create
a small JavaScript project but stop at
designing but again I get sleepy while
learning HTML CSS all that best
practices and cool stuff yeah I guess in
terms of priorities it's I mean you need
to know you need to know all of it I
mean I focus uh
depending on what you want to do I mean
I would focus more on JavaScript you
will pick up your HTML and CSS more
along the way those to me seem to be
more simple especially HTML there's some
tricky things to CSS if you really want
to get into it there are some people
doing really complex things with CSS and
really cool things but for most of us
you know we don't need to be at that
level for a lot of the sites that we
make so you're probably better off
focusing on your JavaScript and then
instead of getting like bogged down in
the Styles just use a framework like
like bootstrap or materialised or if
you're doing react you know you can use
material UI or you know whatever other
framework that way
you won't get as distracted by the
styles in the UI because so much of it
is done for you and then maybe have you
can maybe possibly set a rule for
yourself that you get the site build all
the functionality done first before you
style and then that way you know maybe
you won't get you know stuck and in that
section so I'm not I'm not a hundred
cents sure that that's your issue but
sometimes that that helps me just not
get too caught up in designing first
because you could end up designing for
elements and features that don't even
make
get into your site and then it ends up
being you know a waste of time I mean
you always learn from it but you know it
would take up a lot of your time that
could otherwise be used to you know add
more functionality to your to your
project or you know do more testing and
things so hopefully that that helps all
right that's that's it for the for the
live chat and we basically accomplished
what we set out to which is awesome so I
was a little bit bold and I wrote in the
description to the video he was either
in the description of the video or in my
tweet about it I wrote that I will be
completing this scroll spy knife today
so when I wrote it I thought like what
if I don't complete it I'm gonna I'm
gonna feel silly but we did we completed
it so that's pretty cool
okay Arthur has some follow up here I
read a lot of articles watch courses and
sometimes don't create a single project
yeah I like design and what my projects
to look good I struggle mostly with
layouts and responses yeah yeah Arthur
definitely check out some of the
frameworks that I mentioned because
it'll take care a lot of the response of
the response in this I mean it's good to
know how that works and writing media
queries and things but it's a type of
thing that you really only want to do
from scratch once and then either copy
what you did for other projects or use a
framework because it can be tedious and
I think unnecessarily tedious I don't
think there's a lot of value in
recreating a whole layout system every
single time unless you're doing
something really experimental then it's
better off just to use something
pre-made and in that case something
thoroughly tested you know yeah and make
sure really try to do projects I mean it
I get into the same thing sometimes
where I read a lot of stuff I watch
courses and things like that but
[Music]
try to make sure that you're also
working on projects maybe split up your
time to say like okay I'm gonna spend
this much time each day working on a
project even if I don't get anywhere
like I'm gonna give it a good try and
then you can go to your other resources
because it's important to actually be
the building as well all right Arthur
says thanks for answering your welcome
arthas's I have that bad feeling do it
from Sierra yeah don't worry nobody does
it from zero don't worry about that I
used to feel the same way especially
when I was learning like I got to do it
all from scratch but nobody does it from
scratch like we were talking about
earlier in the stream like if you're
building a react project how much work
has already been done by the react team
at Facebook like so much work there's no
such thing as from scratch for a react
developer you know there's so and in so
many things it's not just react if
you're using angular if you're using
view if you're using any type of testing
you know framework you know whatever you
even if you're just using some
boilerplate HTML code like unless you
wrote it yourself and are copying it
from a former project like still so I
mean we all we all build on what others
have done and that's I think a good
thing so don't worry too much about that
as long as you can produce good work
you know I say it's totally fine to rely
on you rely you know someone on the work
of others and Frankie says thanks sensei
you're welcome I think it's so fun that
you call me sensei all right okay so I'm
gonna end the stream now I've definitely
put in more than my normal amount of
time working
and my kids are home from school so I'm
gonna see them and hopefully get a
workout in I should be back tomorrow I
will be in the office tomorrow we have
like some sort of drill for in case
there's some emergency on campus and
it's in the afternoon so I'm gonna try
not to stream during the time when we're
supposed to have the drill cuz I don't I
don't want to have to leave my office in
the middle of a stream so I'm thinking
maybe in a stream early in the day so
early in the day Eastern Time
so just as a heads-up to you all yeah so
anyway thanks all thanks everyone
especially thanks for all your help
definitely went faster you know because
of all that help and I appreciate all
the all the positivity that you all have
not just today but all the time and
until tomorrow have a wonderful day